foreign
good morning for the benefit of the
viewing public
we will start this meeting a little bit
late about 1005 or so
i'm
you
they were they were ordered a long time
ago okay let's get started everybody
good morning
this is the science technology and
energy committee i'm representative
michael boze i'll be presiding here this
afternoon or this morning
and let us begin by all rising and
joining representative kam brills in the
pledge of allegiance
even the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
okay so this is a full committee work
session it's an organizational meeting
to decide what we're going to do about
six
bills that we
retained in committee for interim study
and we'll go through those bills one by
one
and decide how we want to proceed
proceed if we decide to set up
subcommittees then we will form those
subcommittees and ask for
volunteers
now carrie our
committee admin
and i had discussed probably two weeks
ago now
the possibility that she would provide
copies of all the bills
uh this morning
and she forgot
but i double checked with her she's
working on it and she will be bringing
in copies of all the bills
here
shortly
the the project managers among us will
have supplied their own copies
it's unusual to have a committee session
where there's more people in the
audience than there are members of the
committee
in attendance but part of that is
because
the speaker scheduled a leadership
meeting
opposite this meeting so representative
thomas representative notter
possibly representative harrington are
in the leadership meeting
and they will join us once that meeting
is complete
now we will conclude this meeting no
later than 11 45 because at 12 o'clock
we're scheduled for
a committee lunch at cheers and we hope
uh all members of the committee will be
able to to join us for that
goodbye lunch for um
the second year of our
biennium session
and there is kristin who will be joining
us for lunch i hope
and carrie also will be joining us for
lunch
at cheers this morning
so with that we can start now and we're
going to go through these bills
in the order they are listed
they were listed in the calendar so the
first bill in the calendar was house
bill 1248
which is a
bill
relative to the placement power for net
metering customer generators now this
bill
as you'll recall from the committee
public hearing
and subsequent debate an exec session
was basically just an idea
it had
virtually no implementation strategy
outlined in the legislation
so
in classic
legislative fashion it really does need
some kind of interim study because there
was no possibility that the bill could
move forward otherwise
so
i'm going to suggest that we do
form a subcommittee for this
bill and
in the fall
have that sub committee have at least
one meeting on the subject to try to uh
put something together representative
oxenam did you ever comment a question
it's my memory from our public hearing
that this bill was based on a
misconception that somehow
solar small solar generators were
supposed to be um on the hook for for
doing certain things at certain times
i i see no point in the committee
spending any time on this bill it was it
was a death with dignity vote to say
interim study
but i i see no point in taking up
committee time
ah looks like we might be getting copies
of the bills here shortly
thank you gary
any further comment
on this
the possibility that we might create an
uh subcommittee for interim study on
this bill representative partial
i would con um concur with uh
representative oxfam that i think this
bill needs to have more substance before
we can even take it up an interim study
any further comment representative mcgee
yeah i'll i'll echo what was said and um
and think the concept of the bill
was to say that
that these small customer generators
would have to provide their replacement
power right and it and it came up in the
hearing when
when the representative white testified
on it that the export grid obligations
there is no grid obligation because
those producers are considered
load reducers right and and so we
wouldn't have the advantage of people
independently
um
creating
local generation
if we
change the paradigm and i think this was
a bill that was
trying to explore something and and i
have no problem with that but i don't i
don't think any interim study would
provide us with any solution
along these lines because it's it's not
really a tenable position
having
a grid export obligation from
intermittent sources is just the
opposite it it's the antithesis of the
point
the point is
for them to be able to create that
intermittent power
in order to lower demand
it doesn't have anything to do with them
being on the hook for
grid exports
so they're just two different animals i
think in my opinion
okay thank you
before we
go on any further i would remind
everybody that
when it comes to interim study bills at
this point in the session
there are only two determinations that
we can make one is
that this
we recommend that this bill be
the subject of
future legislation
or the other option is to recommend that
this bill not be
the subject for
future legislation
and
yeah obviously some of you feel that it
should not be the subject of future
legislation
but the question in my mind is since
it's so
underdeveloped and there are so many
questions that are outstanding
how can the committee know for sure one
way or the other whether it should
recommend
for or not for future
legislation if we don't know what the
answers to the questions are
representative lewicki i thank you mr
chairman i think that i don't know
whether the committee or a subcommittee
could add any value to this basically
some it's somebody's idea and that
somebody is the one who has to provide
the impetus rather than us trying to do
so
okay
any other comments
representative oxenoum
there's an opportunity for new
legislation in the fall if if there's an
idea here and needs pursuing the sponsor
can bring it forward again but i i see
no reason to pursue this bill thank you
okay any further comment
representative partial yes thank you
chair um
that's sort of a general question we're
looking at uh six uh potential study
groups here
um
and we are all looking at i believe
limited resources within this committee
um
we are not going to be prioritizing
these as to the
importance of as far as necessity for
having a study committee are we
if i'm being clear or not
sorry what was the question again
we have six uh bills recommended for
interim study
and i'm wondering about the resources we
have to apply to those uh basic study
groups
and
is there any point going through all six
spills and seeing which ones weigh the
heavy heaviliest and have the strongest
need
that's what we're doing today yeah we're
not going to decide right now whether or
not we're going to disclude house bill
we're not oh okay thank you so we're not
we're just going to go through these get
a senses a consensus of
of how we feel about these bills
and then
probably along about 11 o'clock or so
we'll decide yes or no on whether we're
going to do anything representative
pementel
thank you mr chairman
this particular bill
doesn't just need a tweak it needs to be
rewritten
maybe even a different subject matter so
it just
doesn't seem like
it's a it's a bill that
should be
round
uh
filed
okay any further comment
seeing none let's move on to
the next bill we're doing the house
bills first and then we'll do the senate
bills so this will be house bill 1635 fn
which is an act relative to the purchase
of
output of limited electrical energy
producers and including qualified
storage
system
which probably should be systems but
we sent this bill to interim study
because there was a senate bill
which was if you'll refresh my 321
senate bill 321 which we passed
uh
that superseded this bill
so
in the case of this bill i would suggest
that maybe this bill
is not would not be recommended for
further study but i'm open to other
comments
did 321 make it through
yes going for governor yeah 321 should
be on its way to the governor maybe it's
already signed he signed
something like 56 bills a couple days
ago
yeah well i'm okay with not studying it
if that's the case
any other comments
representative bernardi
thank you mr chairman yes i concur we've
already dealt with this issue with the
senate bill this is no need for us to
address it further
future comments further comments
representative can anyone answer for me
whether the storage language ended up in
the final version of 321 because i know
that was one of the goals of the
language when we were first discussing
it was that storage was not accommodated
yet in the statute and so there was an
interest in adding it and i think 321
had that language but i don't know where
it landed so i was just wondering if
anybody knows
it was in the bill
uh and we made no changes to the bill
other than
an amendment that we added and the
senate concurred with that amendment
representative oxendine could we ask our
assistant to just check the senate
amendment the
the bill in its final form to see if
that language sure thank you very much
kristen could you do that for us
yes please thank you
any further comments about
consensus seems to be that we would not
recommend that for future legislation
all right let's move on then
the next one is a big one it's house
bill 1644 this is the
5 g bill that was introduced by
representative
pat abrami
it's relative to the placement of
telecommunications antenna and
establishing a registry for residents
who are experiencing biological symptoms
from with from wireless radiation
exposure
believe that there's a pretty widespread
consensus that we want to do something
with this bill representative callie
pitts
um
i believe that representative myrna
was going to
form a study committee and i think we
should
i think there are a lot of things that
we hear
i'm not sure about i read so much
conflicting information
i really need to get
the other side of the story
and
understand a little bit more about what
5g is so i would recommend that this
does go into interim study
i'd remind members to turn your
microphone off if you're not speaking
representative wiki thank you mr
chairman
we keep using the term 5g and it makes
my teeth itch because it's a misnomer
what we're talking about is various
frequencies and various
a very wide range of frequencies over
which cell phones operate from eight
mega uh 800 megahertz to at least 23
gigahertz that's an enormous spread and
radiation in those bands behaves very
differently
from one band to another and i think we
should be focusing on that technical
aspect of it
rather than an encoding protocol which
can be used on any of those frequencies
and so
i really would like us to go in that
direction and i am certainly willing to
participate in this
so representative thomas who's not here
at the moment but we'll be here in a
shortly
and representative abrami who was the
original sponsor of this bill
have requested
that we form a subcommittee
to study this issue further
and representative thomas has requested
that we have the first meeting of that
subcommittee next tuesday which is may
31st
and i'm okay with that
sounds reasonable to me so
i think we will definitely have a
subcommittee on this bill
and i will open it to anybody who wants
to participate to be a member of that
subcommittee
representative thomas will be there
representative abrami i'm going to
appoint to that subcommittee
and anybody else on this committee who
wants to be on that subcommittee
all you have to do is notify myself or
representative thomas and you will be
added as official members of that
subcommittee representative callie pitts
i'm wondering if the chair would
maybe run it by somebody from health and
human services
since i do believe that
as well as being a technical issue this
is a health issue
at least so they would be aware of
what we're looking at
it's a good idea thank you very much for
that suggestion i'll consult with
representative pearson who's the chair
of hh the hhs committee and see if
there's anybody on his committee who
might have an interest in participating
on that committee
representative oxenam thank you mr chair
i'm wondering if
it's a lovely idea to have anyone who
wants to participate but sometimes we do
get into situations where
voting matters um in the previous
subcommittee on this
anybody could attend and anybody could
participate but when it came to voting
it was only the members of the committee
who voted it seems to me that
that could become an issue
and i'm just suggesting that
you might want to think about that as
you're setting up the committee
it's a good point thank you for raising
that
because there's only two options here
either recommend for future legislation
or not recommend for future legislation
i think that whatever the committee the
subcommittee comes up with
we are all going to get a chance to vote
on the final outcome
and so it's maybe not as as big an issue
as it might otherwise have been
but
my prediction would be
having had several conversations with
representative thomas about this
that
the committee will recommend future
legislation
and it might even recommend
certain types of future legislation
so
that is a very likely outcome of the
subcommittee i shouldn't maybe prejudice
its outcome ahead of time but
it seems likely to me that that that
would be the direction that the
subcommittee would go in
so could i have a show of hands of
people in this uh
room right now who would like to be on
that subcommittee
so representative partial
cali pitts
oxenum
loicky
uh representative wiki no
go ahead representative okay thank you
mr chairman um i think that
representative white had some
significant knowledge to offer on this i
don't know whether he's available
okay representative berezne wants to be
on the committee representative bernardi
no
okay we'll put representative white down
anybody else
okay that's a pretty representative
group
so in addition to representative thomas
and representative abrami
that'll be eight people on the
subcommittee
pending the outcome of my discussion
with representative pearson
about an hhs person
so eight or nine members i think would
be
a good solid
subcommittee to pursue
a direction a future direction for
legislation based on
the original hb 1644 any further
discussion of
representative oxenam
just real quick do you happen to know if
uh representative thomas has decided on
the time on tuesday morning
nine versus ten perhaps or
yeah we'll ask him when he gets back in
here thanks very much i suspect it'll be
but he will have to make that decision
today because
we have to get a notice in the calendar
and it has to be
done by noon tomorrow so
we'll make that he'll make that decision
later today he may have already made it
we'll see when he gets here
any further discussion on 1644.
we're mowing these down pretty quickly
we might be out of here by
11 o'clock at this rate
all right so let's move on
now we'll go to the senate bills
and the first one would be senate bill
now senate bill 259
we
agreed in a
committee of conference to
add language to
house bill 1258
that was substantively similar to the
language in this bill
whereas this bill called for
a municipal host
where
a definition of political subdivision
could mean the state of new hampshire
or
a variety of other
entities
in
house bill 1258
the language we added was simply the
state of new hampshire
so the
state of new hampshire is now considered
in the definition of
political subdivision for the purposes
of
municipal hosting
representative mcgee thank you mr chair
as i recall the conversation there was
some question around um
[Music]
there was a question of quasi-public
entity being too vague and people didn't
understand what that meant
and i sort of went and looked up
that definition and it it's a fairly
well qualified thing but i think that
the senate was trying to add housing
authorities
public entities and the p's development
authority for specific purposes so i
don't know if we ever got any answers on
the house side as to why they were
trying to adopt that language or whether
it is of value
but i know we're just talking about
whether we're going to do a subcommittee
or not but i guess the point would be
whether there was something they were
trying to achieve that we have not yet
achieved that's the only reason i would
want to hang on to it
you know
i do not know what the
reason was for including please peace
development authority it's a good
question to ask i agree
representative callie pitts
i i would think that rather than try to
hang on to this bill
we would simply write a new bill with
new
more direct language as what we want i
think we when i was looking at this one
where it says
the state of new hampshire or any city
town county school district we just have
to uh
write a brand new bill
next year
that would affirm what that is and i
don't think this bill
i think we know that already
that's awesome well you're absolutely
right that no matter
what we recommend recommend here whether
we recommend future legislation or not
recommend future legislation
it's going to require a new bill next
year
so if we say yes
we think this
is a good subject for future legislation
that would have to happen anyway because
this bill itself dies on october
26th
regardless of of what we we choose or
october 28th whatever the deadline is
representative oxendine did you have
another comment
i'm a little taken aback by your october
26 october 28th so i i if i could step
back and allow you to
explain that further before i make my
comment thank you mr chair
okay so if you look in the calendar
on
page two
house deadlines
it says friday october 28th last day to
file 2022 interim study reports
so on that day or before we have to have
filed a report that says
sb 259 is recommended or not recommended
for future legislation
so that's what that's the deadline thank
you it wasn't anything particular to
this bill that you were suggesting it
was just the the common
deadline for all interim study bills
correct thank you for clarifying that
no problem
there were two issues with this bill one
was the addition of particular entities
such as quasi public entity and we were
informed that that was particularly
directed to the university of new
hampshire system and the community
college systems
but
in certain negotiations outside of
committee there was a discussion at
least of
not proceeding with those particular
aspects but focusing on the deletion of
the one line the one sentence on lines
eight through ten
this particular sentence is a real
problem we have had no uptake of this
possibility that was presented to
municipalities and the counties
and now the state of new hampshire
because it is so limiting not only i you
know i
anybody remembers the the color
coordinated map our towns are not big
enough to have the load necessary within
their boundaries to act particularly
many of our towns have overlapping
utility territories
when you say it they all group members
have to be within the same utility
territory and they have to be within the
same municipality you have made this a
null category
for any but the very largest cities and
our very largest cities don't have the
terrain
to actually
go out and often i i won't say it
completely
a it's a difficulty in a built-up area
in in my partic my district we have a
perfect place to put a solar array we
have towns that are committed to
transitioning to alternative energy
this
this rsa would make it possible for them
to do something very positive but only
if we can delete this
this restriction which really is
incompatible and and we discussed this
at the public hearing
that you're saying it has to be within a
certain one single municipality but this
the state could be an entity and the
county could be the entity so
eliminating this one sentence i think i
think it is worthwhile for us to have
this study so that we could proceed
because this this really is a matter of
state importance
thank you
thank you i i agree with you that that
maybe we should
do some work to figure out whether
allowing multiple multiple
municipalities to be in a
group
a municipal host group is a good thing
or not and what it what what the
implications would be how much it would
cost etc
um
that's a valid
area for future study i would think and
possible future legislation as well so
is there any appetite amongst committee
members for forming a subcommittee to
study
if nothing else at least that question
apparently so so
we'll sit
seriously consider setting up a
subcommittee on this one then
representative callie pitts
i have another question it's
a municipality
on contiguous municipalities
so i'm thinking of portsmouth
i'll use portsmouth as an example
portsmouth right now could become
a community and greenland could join
that
and newington could join that
i believe because now we're in the same
political area
including newcastle so i just think that
we need to get some
i agree with we but i think we need to
get some concrete areas answers on what
that means
because i didn't think you had to be i
mean an individual municipality i
thought
contiguous
uh municipalities could now participate
together
and no that's not not in this bill
the existing legislation does not allow
that the definition of municipal group
hosting
restricts it to a single municipality
and
the purpose of of a future study
according to the re recommendation of
representative oxygen would be to
discover whether
um
that limitation should be lifted and
what the implications of doing that
might be is am i correct about that
representative oxenum
yes may i phillip sir
under the impression that that was
either implicit or implied in 315 the
community power
well
you're
you're confusing maybe the community
power aspect
and the
municipal group hosting aspect they were
both in the same bill because the senate
added
an amendment to 315 to add the
group municipal hosting piece
but they're different entities they're
not the same thing
um
i i'll allow you to make that comment
but please turn on your mic for
clarification
yep i was just saying one is designed to
move across municipal lines and the
other one still has an exclusion that
says it is not
correct so that's why it's confusing
because they were both lumped together
in the same bill but they're two
different programs essentially
and this one
as representative oxenon points out
the group groupnet
metering municipal hosting program may
still be
a little too limited
in order to be effective and so we ought
to study whether that's the case or not
i would agree with that i think it's a
it's a reasonable thing to look at
any further discussion on that question
okay seeing none
let me have a show of hands of people
who would be willing to serve on a
subcommittee to look into this question
representative bernardi
representative oxenom
[Music]
representative mcwilliams
representative berner
anybody else representative mcgee
okay
sounds like we'll go forward with the
subcommittee then to study
the questions raised by senate bill 259
any further discussion on
senate bill 259
okay
let's move on
next step would be senate bill 264.
and that is
relative to certain references
to the department of energy and
transferring authority over the low
income electric
electricity assistance program to the
department of energy
and
does anyone on the committee remember
the discussion
in the public hearing
or the executive session that led us to
interim study this bill
representative oxenom
we had a number of bills dealing with
the transfer of authority to department
of energy so it's difficult to
remember exactly which one this was but
i think the the issue here
was the low-income
uh
provisions of reggie that there might
have been
[Music]
an issue there with the puc and and that
we thought it deserved a further look
but it was not it it wasn't a
contentious issue or one that
we really gave a lot of attention to it
that that's my recollection
thank you it's coming back to me now i
think the objection that some members of
the committee had to this bill was that
the low-income program fund
would be allowed to accumulate
year over year
and
there was the potential
for the amount of money to accumulate in
this fund to be
substantial is that the way you remember
it representative bernardi
yes mr chairman
i agree it was the accumulation issue
so if accumulating funds in this
program was the question or was the
issue
then
the next question is is this something
that we should take a closer look at
representative oxenon
we have a tremendous need for
weatherization programs and we've had a
long history of long long waiting lists
waiting lists that are so long that
people don't even add their names to the
waiting list so the notion that we're
going to have a problem of accumulating
money seems to me to be a
a very much an
uh a reach to to look for for an issue
or a problem our problem has been
insufficient funds and too great of need
with our current energy crisis with the
rising costs of volatile fossil fuels
that the best way we can act to help the
people of new hampshire
lower electricity costs is to help them
with weatherization
and uh at at no time has it been more
important for us to make these funds
available so i i see no problem about
an issue with
accumulation
and the other problem is that we have
all these strange
non-calendar dates when things get
reported and things get allocated so
that oftentimes you have a disconnect
and money gets put into something and
then it's not available to be accessed
because it wasn't in the same fiscal
year or wasn't in some particular
calendar
deadline
this having the continuation means that
the funds that are there people know
they're there when they're allocated
they know they're there when they apply
uh that the people that are out there
doing the work can rely on the funding
stream it's important for our businesses
it's important for our our constituents
i i think that this is
is is important
and therefore we shouldn't be rocking
the boat and putting it under doubt by
saying oh maybe we need to study whether
or not this is a good idea or not
we need to leave this alone and let it
let it do the job
so you don't do not want to study so i
do not think there's any point in
starting i think it would be a negative
two okay to do that representative
callie pitts
i think we need to
re-look at this bill or to study it i
think one of the problems that comes up
is the pre-qualification problem
and to me that's a problem
and
reading over what the department of
energy says that
you know federal funds could be in
jeopardy i think we just it bears
another look
okay one vote for one vote against
uh a subcommittee representative
harrington
uh one thing i would just wanted to
mention on this is that we just had the
newest puc rule on
uh weatherization and spending energy
efficiency and i think i can't remember
exactly what i think was 60 had to go on
electric reduction
uh programs
65 okay now i know in the past before
the rules have changed the utilities
came to the puc and said we can't spend
the system benefit charge the portion
that goes not to commercial but goes to
residential because you go into
someone's house and you say oh we placed
all your light bulbs and now you can buy
a new refrigerator but it's going to
cost you 400 but we're going to give you
uh 75 towards that they'll say well you
know come back in four or five years
when my refrigerator breaks
and they said they that's where the
program got switched and allowed a lot
more uh the money being spent on thermal
issues so with that new restriction at
65 going to electric uh use reduction we
may run into this thing where it gets up
to that million dollars i just think
that's worth probably looking at a
little closer to see if it is going to
be an issue i just don't know but but i
know in the past it had been and we're
not going to 100 to reduce electric
consumption with the money but we're
doing 65
we may find that some of that money just
doesn't get used on the residential side
representative lewicky thank you mr
chairman one question i have is excuse
me that
and i may have a false impression is
that typically low-income people are
living in rental properties and
how it the mechanism for doing that
essentially would benefit the landlords
who may not actually be low-income
people i may be wrong
it's a good
question any further representative
partial yes thank you chair
um i'm reading that where uh
if the department of junction
accumulates over one million dollars
excess is not likely to be substantially
reduced the department injury may
uh using a non-adjudicative process uh
suspended further collection to me that
seems like a reasonable clause
but if people would like to see that
either the dollar figure
or see their language
but maybe exchange that rather than may
to must
i mean i could live with that i could
think a study group could probably
hammer that issue out to the
satisfaction of
all parties concerned so my
recommendation would be to go ahead with
a study committee on this
that and the
federal funding i'm concerned about
thank you
further comments
all right let's see a show of hands of
people who would
support
doing a subcommittee for this bill
one two we're talking
264. 264. senate bill 264.
people who would support
having a subcommittee study the issues
for this bill
one
two three four
anybody opposed to doing a subcommittee
for this bill
one
two
three four
five
all right looks like uh
the fi the nose out vote the yeses on a
subcommittee
and so what we'll do then is come fall
we'll just make a decision one way or
the other
we recommend it for future legislation
or we don't
so that's what that's what we'll do in
the fall on this one
with no subcommittee
right before we move on to
another bill
i would like to ask representative
thomas
to talk for a few minutes about
house bill
and his vision for
where it's going to go in the future we
had a lengthy discussion about it and
we've identified
these people in addition to yourself and
representative abrami
as members of a subcommittee and i'm
going to speak to representative pearson
to find out if there might be an hhs
person who would be
interested in serving on the
subcommittee so doug if you could tell
us a little bit about your vision going
forward i know you talked about a may
31st meeting if you could tell us when
time what time that meeting would be
uh that would be helpful okay um well i
wasn't here for when the subcommittee
members were being discussed but i know
that a couple of days ago representative
partial
indicated a desire to be on that
committee if
there's room for that
okay
i didn't get your name the first time
around
i um so my desire is to meet on the 31st
to
set the stage for
possible
other interim study meetings that might
occur in the fall
my objective is
to see if
something can be done
to
mitigate people's concerns
on what they have
my feeling is that
business
may be able to
accommodate at very little or no cost to
themselves by just maybe changing a few
ideas or maybe
doing things one way versus another way
to accomplish the same thing that might
help but
i've asked vendors to come through our
lobbies here to come on tuesday to talk
about
ways that they might be able to help
people
not trying to debate whether the
technology does or doesn't actually
affect them but in what ways can they
accommodate
their technology going forward that can
at least help some of these people
understand that something's trying to be
done
um
and not placing blame on any one thing
or another per se
just what can we do to help
you know can we put things in a
different position can we put things in
a different
area can things can can
some
some distance be used um maybe not as
much as what this original bill called
uh called for but something
to show the people that they're trying
to accommodate something
just to see if it's possible
and
my expectation
for those that come to the meeting on
tuesday from
the vendor side is
i want to hear what
you
some ideas
of of what could be done i really don't
want to hear the same information
because we know the same information
about what your technical scientific
background says we all know that but
what can you do
to help mitigate
some of these people's concerns
i don't know what it is
i don't know if we can
but i want to hear some ideas
and i think based on what we hear on the
31st we can perhaps move forward to
another meeting in the fall to see
if any legislation is required to do
anything or maybe not maybe they can do
things on their own we're not sure i
just want to make sure that we
find out what we can do
to show
that
we're doing everything we can
to accommodate people within within
reason and within the technical aspects
of what they're trying to do i have
heard rumors that
since our
big meetings that we that we had here
that they've discovered that some
some things aren't working the way that
they want to so they may be making some
changes that's fine i want to hear about
that too so that's that's my vision it's
just how can how can the vendors show us
that they're trying to you know
help these people in one way or another
and just
just so that we can see what's what's
going forward aside from that that's
that's my goal to start on the 31st and
again that will dictate what we do in
the fall
what time on the 31st
uh well i
i i would stick to the regular 10
o'clock meeting
give people a chance to come down here
okay 10 o'clock on the 31st you've all
been alerted
it will be in the calendar
representative thomas will take care of
making sure that happens
okay
any other comment on 1644
before we move
on okay seeing none
we'll now move on to the last bill
in our group
which is senate bill 269 fn which was a
bill
relative to the new hampshire
weatherization program
this bill
reduces contractor pre-qualifications
for contracts pertaining to the new
hampshire weather resistance
assistance program
and calls for the weatherization of
repurposed buildings such as mill
buildings
and
the question here is
does this bill warrant the formation of
a subcommittee to study the issues
representative mann has some opinions
yes i've done some um you know
back of the envelope
financial modeling of
statewide energy efficiency
value and it's enormous value to
to the state we send
i think
multi hundreds of millions of dollars
out of state to buy oil
and it's all burned up uh and it
produces co2
um
and that could be
sharply cut back uh other states have
done that and they've been busy on it
the
point that i um
made when i sent out i think a paper to
everybody here
was that
when a weatherization program doing one
house well and then going to the next
one and then to the next and then to the
next
you have an accumulating a lot of
steadily growing number of
uh houses that are saying
that have cut their
oil consumption or their fossil fuel
consumption
and um
so
whatever weatherization you did five
years ago is still producing savings
what you did four years ago is still
producing savings
in three and two and one
and when you sketch it out it's an
accelerating gain
of value to the state to save all that
money
and
the investment
in weatherization is a straight line
you spend the same amount roughly you
know as figure averages
every year to weatherize more and more
houses or maybe the same number of
houses are the same
amount of reduction in co2 production or
same reduction in oil expense
and so that's a straight line
and the acceleration
of the reduction
of uh
energy consumption in
in homes
is a parabola it's an x squared it's a
accelerating thing and if you draw the
graphs of those two there is absolutely
no combination
of a straight line graph and a parabola
where they do not intersect where
the linear
growth in
investment
stays steady
the
savings that you achieve year by year
accelerate
those curves cross
and in a few maybe a decade or so
like massachusetts
the program is paying for itself
paying for itself
and the
gap between what's being saved and
what's
being invested increases year after year
um
it may not be three years or five years
it might be 50 years it depends on you
know the exact cost the conditions of
the houses and we'll find that out by
doing this but this
uh this committee this commission
uh should be studying
the financial aspects
we should be this is a very serious
thing it's not only serious to the
homeowner that has to pay for the fuel
but it's serious in our economy if you
drain this kind of money out of our
economy people have less to spend and
everybody loses a little bit
we badly need an analysis
such as the other states around us have
done
to understand what the
really an economic effect of an energy
efficiency program
would be
and if it's
um
you know if it's if it's
minor if it's insignificant which is
surely not the case
uh
you know we can stop worrying about it
but i think the outcome of such a study
would be beneficial and it would be
fact-based
it would be intellectually sound it
wouldn't be just yelling back and forth
from one side to the other
thank you
okay representative harrington
uh thank you mr speaker maybe someone
can help you out a little bit with this
bill cause i'm trying to go back here
it seems as if the main crux of it is
getting rid of the pre-qualification
requirements for
contractors who would be using this the
system benefit money or any other state
or ratepayer money to
install
weatherization at with the businesses or
houses and
can maybe someone can refresh me what is
the issue with this what we have listed
here is that they have to have all the
licenses necessary they have to have
insurance they have to maintain this and
so forth and so on what is that what is
this going away that's causing
apparently causing a problem in this
pre-qualification process i just don't
remember what it was
well if you look at the fiscal note on
the back of the
a printout of the legislation that we
have the department of energy indicated
that
changing the pre-qualification
criteria in the middle of a program year
could jeopardize some federal funding
and i think that was the primary reason
why we decided this bill needed to be
studied further it had nothing to do
with
weatherization per se it was the
question of whether there might be some
number of federal funds
currently the state
program receives about 1.9 million in
federal funds
an additional 18.5 million in one-time
money
from the federal infrastructure bill
and non-compliance with the department
of energy regulations could result in
federal funds not being awarded to the
state so that's a that's a question that
we need to figure out i guess and a
legitimate reason i think for
putting this bill into interim study
and so i guess what we're saying is we
need to look at the department of energy
regulations and see if we're violating
them because
it sounds like it wouldn't just affect
doing it in the middle of a funding year
wouldn't it be back next year the same
thing if we're not
okay i'm sorry if we're not in
compliance with their regulations we
stand to lose federal money and you know
how onerous are the regulations i guess
is the balancing act if if it costs uh
the contractors so much money to
pre-qualify that they have to spend on
stuff that they're not spending on
insulation then you know maybe in the
long run the federal money's not worth
it but i think it's worth looking into
to answer that question
i i can't tell by this that's not my
point it is hard to tell and that is why
the bill was sent to interim study
because this is
it's an outstanding question needs to be
addressed
and of course there's two department of
energies here one is the state
department of energy and the other is
the national department of energy that
apparently their
pre-qualification
criteria may come into some
conflict or
maybe it's just the national department
of energy criteria recall
pre-qualification criteria that's in
question here but either way
it's a question that needs to be
answered representative man
i i agree we should be studying this
there's a lot of potential here and
this
we didn't debate this bill
in set in our session
it came up
it was um recognized a motion to um
refer and uh we voted on it immediately
there wasn't a word of discussion
so i think um
at the very least we ought to assign a
subcommittee to look into
this bill thanks
all right how many let's uh have a show
of hands how many people think we should
have a form a subcommittee for this bill
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
okay eight
anybody opposed to forming a
subcommittee
nobody's opposed so
let's go ahead and form a subcommittee
then
for this bill
okay volunteers to serve on this
subcommittee
representative oxen are you volunteering
or do you want to speak
go ahead and speak
um now that i see that i've volunteered
if i were to volunteer for this one i
would have be on three
so i would like to remove myself from
the 5g if i may use that term uh
committee and so that i could volunteer
for this one
okay i have crossed you off the
5g thank you very much okay who else
wants to be on this subcommittee
representative callie pitts
representative mann i'm sure
anybody else representative partial
representative merner
anybody else
representative kimbrils
okay
so we have a
representative group of
of folks to serve on this subcommittee
representative thomas i think mr um
since uh representative oxnam has
withdrawn us all from the 1644
subcommittee representative um
nodder would would like to be appointed
in instead
oh
so we'll put you on it
so it turns out that the copies of the
bills that we received this morning
were the
copies of the bill as introduced
and that the
amended bills
may and in some cases have been quite
different
and this is one of those bills senate
bill 269. apparently the version that we
were looking at here is quite different
from the amended version
and
griffin robarge from the department of
energy is here today and is willing to
discuss with us
the
senate
passed version of the bill to give us
an idea what the differences might be
we're still going to study the bill i
think but
mr robarge would you like to help us out
figure out what additional topics we
need to study
thank you appreciate you being here
thank you chairman votes members of the
committee for the record griffin roberge
i simply just wanted to note that it
appeared that the committee's discussion
was centering around senate bill 269 fn
as introduced
that bill was significantly amended by
the senate to just
turn into a proposed study commission
that would quote
establish a commission to study methods
of participation for maintaining an
energy savings weatherization program
to assist in lowering the overall energy
consumption for new hampshire families
again a commission versus what you have
in front of you i think you'd agree
might be significantly different i just
simply wanted to make the committee
aware of that that's it
good thank you for bringing that to our
country
again
what was that could you repeat yeah i'm
just reading the bill analysis it
establishes a commission to study
methods of participation
for maintaining an energy savings
weatherization program
to assist in lowering the overall energy
consumption for new hampshire families
if it helps at all i can certainly
forward along a copy of the amended bill
to the committee following this meeting
i don't think that'll be necessary
because we've already decided we're
going to have a study subcommittee to
look at it just letting you just letting
everybody know okay thank you appreciate
that thank you presentative man
okay representative callie pitts did you
have a comment
apparently not
okay
all right so we figured out we're going
to uh
we're going to have us a subcommittee to
look at this bill before we make a
recommendation i i would think the
recommendation would be to
to
recommend future legislation
based on
the amended version of the bill
we have to figure out what
triggered our concern about it and then
figure out how to address that
in our report recommending future
legislation
so any further comment about that
representative oxenam
i'm a little confused and i it would
have been nice if we'd had the text of
that
of
before us
i you know if if the concern was about
fiscal participation of propane and you
know i remember that discussion people
going what in the you know what does
that even mean that's not the bill
anymore that that's not the subject and
there would be that would not be
something that the interim study group
would be looking at the interim study
group is only looking at whether or not
to have a commission on participation
it
no the interim study group
would look at the bill
that was
amended by the senate which was the one
we actually
passed judgment on not not the
introduced version that we're looking at
here right
and the the committee would the
subcommittee would have to decide
do we want to recommend this for future
legislation
or not but but this is a commission
to study participation yes
but of course the devil's always in the
details right so
um
let's say for example that the bill and
i don't remember this because i don't
have it right in front of me but let's
say for example that the bill
talked about
um
monetizing
trying to remember the language of the
bill figuring out how to get propane and
oil to participate in weatherization
programs
and
if the committee wanted to recommend the
bill for future legislation it could
recommend that it do so by striking that
language by removing that those
references
okay so representative mcgee is going to
read us the exact language i'm sorry
thank you representative i just went
back and checked and the version that i
have is as amended by the senate so i
have the senate amended version and it's
not in the little tiny print either
so and it's the same language that um mr
roberts read for us on the amended
analysis page so i do have that bill and
it does include that language still
um and and all it really says is that um
you know it's listing the duties of the
committee and one of the duties is
policy direction to further prioritize
weatherization within the existing new
hampshire saves programs
and research to explore expanding the
fiscal participation of propane and oil
users in new hampshire in the same
manner as electric and natural gas
and i do think that was something that
was that people said oh that's what this
is about but i think it does make sense
for us to at least look at the
participation because if you spread
things further they cost less
individually and
and it it's similar to
the problem that we're having with the
gas tax you know as the money goes down
in one area we we don't secure as much
in order to provide money for these
programs so
i i think it's just another part of the
analysis that they decided to include
that we look at it so um so that is all
still in here
this is as amended by the senate that's
the bill
i i think i'm understanding
participation in a different in a
different way now
yeah okay it does it does
make some sense there's two words there
fiscal participation which
definitely means
figuring out a way to tax oil and gas to
get them to participate
and that was an issue that the committee
had some concerns about
so
moving forward if we were to recommend
future legislation we might recommend it
without
language about fiscal participation well
i just would as i was
i was only reading the first couple here
but it does also say they would look at
the use of other funding sources such as
grant funds
and explore the fiscal feasibility of
double or triple pane replacement winds
so windows insulated doors water heaters
it's basically saying
where do we get the best bang for the
buck how does everything you know how
does it all fit together where should
the money be spent i i don't i just
think it's
just an examination
okay representative callie pitts
i think i'm losing my mind but i don't
remember ever getting the amended
version
did we
yeah the senate was the
version that was introduced
to us at the public hearing yes the
senate amended version was the version
that was introduced to us
and did it leave out that
my main concern was that
pre-qualification and did it leave that
out it took struck that right yeah
because it turned the whole bill
basically into a commission
yeah okay correct
any further discussion on this uh
representative man yes i i i took the
bill as having the right general thrust
and a lot of the details uh
you know not that important or not quite
well worded you know i i had developed
an amendment to present that day we
didn't get a chance to to hear it but
um
i think if we follow the general thrust
of trying to study
what its benefits are how to maximize
the benefits how to do it
why to do it all of those things whether
to do it
is what this bill should be about
and so for example a bit about getting
the propane and
oil
people to contribute to the thing
uh maybe
maybe the contribution of um
reducing oil consumption
by the state um
to the
health of the economy of the state given
how much we're sending away to buy oil
um
you know handles it so
i think we have to look at this as a
general uh it's a first attempt the bill
i don't think it was well written
uh it didn't sound like a
a a legal bill that you know
but it had a whole lot of suggestions
and a whole lot of
good good intentions in it and so i
think that's what the way we should look
at the bill
this in other words the subcommittee
should be allowed to
make big improvements to that bill
and it should not be difficult
and the study would give us a factual
and a solid basis for making decisions
about this
thank you representative partial thank
you chair i think you've already decided
we're having committee that is true or
yes and uh
i i can see there's language here that
i'm very concerned about we have a
because the commission recommended
commission is
in excess of 24 people
and i just
think it's great to have a large table
to have to invite everybody be part of
it on the one hand but uh i would hate
to try to uh have to schedule it um so i
think it's i think it's imperative to
have a committee that's to work these
kind of things or to have a study uh
commission
study group
before prior to the committee even
though it seems a bit strange to have a
study group to see if we should have a
study group basically
well the subcommittee can
decide if it wants to recommend this
bill for future legislation it doesn't
have to be a commission
the
subcommittee could say we recommend that
the future legislation be x y and z
not necessarily just exactly what the
senate bill
that you might hope recommended so
the subcommittee can come up with
whatever they want you know basically
and then then the full committee will
have to vote in the fall on the
subcommittee's recommendation
yes or no
and that will go forward as the report
that gets delivered to the clerk
about the status of this bill remember
we only have two options we can
recommend it for future legislation
and say why
or we cannot recommend it for future
legislation and say why that will be the
two options that we'll vote on
in the fall for all six of these bills
representative partial
thank you again for clarification um
my understanding is we also will be able
to uh
adapt this though now
if we if we want to recommend it we can
recommend it with
i don't know if amendment
we can amend it and then recommend it
no
so all we'll do is we'll say we
recommend
sb
[Music]
269 for future legislation because
we believe that
x y and z
are important
for future legislation or something like
that and then of course x y and z will
be filled in with actual
recommendations
uh for future legislation
and then it'll be up to somebody
who's an existing or an elected
legislator in the fall
to introduce such a bill
if they so choose
pardon
representative caliph current rep
representatives even if they are not
coming back can introduce that
legislation
i do believe
and that
that co-sponsors can pick it up i i do
believe that yes someone who is
currently in office could file the
legislation in september if they don't
get reelected or choose not to run in
november than at one of their
co-sponsors could pick up the
legislation i just wanted that clear
thank you
okay any further discussion
all right i think we've disposed of all
these bills let's go over them one more
time to make sure we get it right
so senate bill
or house bill
i think we should have a uh subcommittee
on this but
i know a lot of members decided they
didn't agree
is there anybody who would serve on a
subcommittee
regarding this bill
i would serve
is there anybody else who would be
willing to take a look at this
nobody okay we're not going to do a
study committee on sb
or hb 1258
48.
hb 1635 we're not going to do a study
committee on that
we decided hb 1644 we are going to do a
study committee on that
and representative thomas is organizing
all that
hb 259
we decided we do want to have a study
committee on that correct
here
well i've lost my paperwork on that one
already
mr chair i have i wrote a list on that
oh yeah here it is 259 okay
all right so we have
oh this
is for 16 44.
all right so it looks like
we have bernardi mcwilliams mirner mcgee
and partial signed up for the
subcommittee on 2 59. exactly
very forgiving sure i was under the
impression you were asking if i we were
interested in seeing a study committee i
would be interested in seeing a study
committee but already being on
um
one
oh okay i could do that
okay all right
but you asked me to
scratch your name off that one
oh the 5g okay
okay so you do want to be honest it goes
on there okay
all right so we have bern bernardi
oxendine mcwilliams
murder mcgee and partial for
sb 259 right
i would refer to
representative partial
i think that you probably would prefer
me to be on
sb 269
and uh i really should not you know more
than two videos i feel
um
okay so we'll take you off 259 and put
you on 269.
i already have you on that one
okay
okay 264.
we said no on that one no subcommittee
right
and then subcommittee on 269
is oxymitz
man partial murder and chem brills
pimentel you want to be on that one too
rod uh yes i changed my mind about it i
originally i did i was happy with the
bill the way it was
um and i still unhappy with the way the
bill was but i think that
representative
mann
said what needed to be said was that we
can just change some of the wording and
do the same thing
and have it work so i'd i'd like to be
involved in
changing that wording thank you
okay so i've added representative
pimentel to that
subcommittee uh representative merner
could you lead that subcommittee
all right we'll make representative
murder the chair
and the other subcommittee
uh 259 representative bernardi could you
be the chair of that committee
subcommittee
yes mr chairman
okay so representative bernardi will be
the chair
so it'll be the responsibility of you
chairs to schedule a meeting
for the subcommittee in the fall
and you'll have to you coordinate uh
scheduling that subcommittee meeting
with carrie
morris our committee admin
and it needs to be done a week before
the committee meeting
is held so if you want to hold it on
september 14th let's say you have to
notify notify her by september 7th
to get it in the calendar
uh representative callie pitts
just want to clarify the committees are
open to anyone
and it would be up to the committee
chairs if they allow participation of
anyone
or are you going to say you're opening
it up to participation
and number three
when you schedule these meetings keep in
mind that if we're going to put in
even as a committee future legislation
it would be have to be by october
right
the
according to the calendar deadlines
information on page two of the calendar
tuesday september 6th is the
first day for incumbents running for
reelection to file lsrs with complete
information
and then friday september 16th
is the last day
prior to the general election for
incumbents running for re-election to
file lsrs with complete information
so if you intend to file an lsr in
september you have to be
filed to run for re-election
if you've decided not to run for
re-election you cannot file an lsr
in september
and the chairs of the subcommittees
will allow any member of this committee
to participate in the subcommittee
members of meetings if they
want to participate
but only the members of the subcommittee
will vote on the
committee recommendation
for
action on the bill either
yes for future re
recommendation or no for future
legislative recommendations
all right so
with that
do we have any further house business to
conduct before we go off and enjoy lunch
together as a group
i would like to thank all of you for
your hard work this obsession
it's been a difficult session with the
first year being
mostly remote
the second year i thought was was much
more enjoyable
having all of you here in committee
meetings every day
that we held them
and
i thought we
we had an excellent output for our
committee for this year and i look
forward to seeing those of you who will
be returning
next year
if you're running for reelection let's
see a show of hands so i'll know
who may be coming back
okay if you're not running for
reelection a show of hands
representative man and representative
oxen i'm two longtime members of this
committee we thank you very much for
your service to our state and to our
committee we'll miss you
and
i'm sure we'll have an opportunity to
see you again in this building
uh on occasion
but we'll miss your your daily uh
participation
anybody else have anything they'd like
to say before we
call it a day
okay
we're done
we're going to cheers
which
for 12 o'clock we have a reservation
we'll be taking
carrie and kristen
to lunch with us
and
representative thomas i think reserved
a place for 18 or 19 people so
that's right we have a
they have a um i'm not sure if it's a
back room or back section but they'll
have one table for all of us might be in
the shape of an l
um drinks are on your own
alcoholic drinks are on your own
right
and lunch is on your own
uh it's corner yeah right across the
street from the shopping center
representative did you have a comment
i was
with as long as representative thomas
was speaking about the arrangements that
he's made i wanted to thank him for this
and and the many many field trips that
we've had and just
wanted to throw it back to him one more
time if there was anything else about
the block island trip that you felt we
needed to know uh well um
i don't know how many from this
committee are actually going for sure
uh i know i am but i'm not the one
handling it
you had to reserve through the
online link i know that uh that i'll be
taking the bus from the lob which will
meet with anyone leaving from the lb
they'll pick them up in front of the of
the lb and i believe it was
1 30 i believe
that's all i know dress to be on the
boat
um that's all that's that's all i know
really
okay uh i suggested that the bus could
conceivably make a stop in nashua at the
bus station or someplace and pick up
people from the south is that possible
no i know i at this point i don't think
it is the buses only portsmouth and
concord were the only buses that they
were arranging
so if you will get
you i um i did get word back that you
will not get paid
for the out of state travel
you will get mileage i should say for
in-state um
as far as that goes so if you're driving
in concord to take up the bus you get
models for that
i suppose if you're driving from
somewhere else into
portsmouth i think you'll get mileage
for that too
it's also important to understand this
is apparently a multi-state
legislative tour so people from maine
will be coming down
people from massachusetts and rhode
island maybe i don't know so it's not
just new hampshire legislators and we're
not in control of the of the
arrangements that those are being held
uh done by someone else if you have any
other questions i would contact kate
horgan
uh for anything additional that that's
all i know right now
don't miss the boat
representative harrington yeah one other
quick note uh they brought up this
morning the uh uh speaker's ice cream
social is going to be thursday so we
will have probably an extended lunch
uh during the session on thursday just
to plan accordingly and but the thought
is we won't be out of here too late
after that but it will definitely be a
lunch break and we'll be coming back in
the afternoon so
perfect thank you very much
okay everybody thanks so long